[Music]
do something you're very passionate
about and don't try to chase what is
kind of the hot Passion of the day I
think we saw it in the internet World
quite a bit where you know at the sort
of peak of the internet in say 1999
found people who were very passionate
something they kind of left that job and
decided I'm gonna you know do something
in the internet because it's you know it
was almost like the 1849 gold rush in a
way at that time everybody who was in
was within the shouting distance of
California was you know they might have
been a doctor but they quit being a
doctor and they started panning for gold
and that almost never works and even if
it does work you know According to some
Metric financial success or whatever it
might be I suspect it leaves you
ultimately unsatisfied so you really
need to be very clear with yourself and
I think one of the best ways to do that
is this notion of projecting yourself
forward to age 80 looking back on your
life and trying to make sure you've
minimized the number of rats you have
that works for career decisions it works
for family decisions hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn some lessons from
billionaires on how to build a fortune
enjoy
rule number two is make sacrifices with
Bill Gates I think
you know you can over worship and
mythologize the idea of working
extremely hard for my particular makeup
I mean it really is true that I didn't
believe in weekends I didn't believe in
vacations I mean you know I knew
everybody's license plate so I could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so I don't recommend it a I don't
think most people would enjoy it uh once
I got into my 30s I could hardly even
imagine how I had done that uh because
by then some natural behavior kicked in
and I loved weekends and uh you know my
girlfriend liked vacations and that
turned out to be kind of a neat thing uh
now I take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so disgusted with my uh
current uh uh self you know I I was sure
I would never do anything but riding
coach you know now I have a plane so
it's it's very much counter-revelations
and taking place at high speed but yes
it is nice if during those first several
years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty maniacal about the company and
how far that goes you should have a
mutual understanding see or not uh one
person expecting one thing another
person expect another thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know health or relatives or things
that are distracted but yes I have a
fairly hardcore View
that there should be a very large uh
sacrifice made during those
those early years rule number three is
stay in your circle of competence with
Warren Buffett how come you haven't
bought Amazon is there still time to buy
would you still buy oh I I always
admired Jeff I mean I met him 20 years
ago or so and I thought he was something
special but I didn't realize you could
go from books to it what's happened
there no I I mean he had a vision and
executed in an incredible way
but there's a lot of games like this I
would have missed you know I would have
missed Microsoft even if I got into no
bill earlier or something those just
aren't my games I don't worry about the
things that I miss that are outside my
circle of competence of evaluating I I
do I have missed things that were within
my circle and that's a terrible mistake
those are my biggest mistakes you
haven't seen them it's not a mistake
because I miss Netscape or something
like that at all I would say that maybe
five percent of the companies are ten
percent of the companies that most are
within an area my circle of confidence
there's something I should be able to
understand rule number four is grow from
mistakes with Elon Musk what were your
biggest obstacles or mistakes
that you have faced and how did you
overcame it and maybe you can also give
us the students here a piece of advice
and that will be very amazing thank you
to be frank I've made so many mistakes
that it would take far too long for me
to list them all
um
so I I would know where both people
would be the extremely long list of
mistakes that I've made in the past the
higher principle here is that it is
always too aspire to be less wrong over
time so to acknowledge that you'll
always be to some degree wrong but that
you wish to be less wrong over time and
and uh
and if you can be a little less wrong
every day I think you're doing great
um it's it's hard to be less wrong every
day but frankly even if you do that's
wrong most days that that's a pretty big
victory a number of things that I've
said before publicly so
um you know I think it's important to to
place weight upon both the heart and the
mind not simply the mind
um some of the biggest mistakes that
I've made in terms of hiring people have
been when they were
strong of mind but not of heart just
assume you're wrong and you want to be
less wrong and just try to be less wrong
every day
um seek critical feedback especially
from Friends
um often your friends will know what
what you're what what you're saying is
wrong but they don't want to hurt your
feelings so they won't tell you but if
you ask them to tell you and say that it
won't hurt your feelings then they will
tell you
so I think getting critical feedback
from friends is very helpful also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is shift your
thinking with Ray dalio Once you have a
fear
that you might be wrong
but you have still the audaciousness
encouraged to go forward
you're a lot smarter
than the person who thinks they know
there's a there's a quote that Jefferson
said
he who knows he knows not is closer to
the truth than he whose mind is filled
with falsehoods and and so when you know
that and with and then with your
character and your determination you go
forward the smartest people I know
are the most humble
it what the more you learn the more you
realize oh I'm eager to take in so
that's right
um but back on your audience
I I think your audience ranges from um
you know there's a wide range that you
have in your audience
and I would say that there are many
people in your audience
who can plan
for a simple lifestyle that can be
wonderful sometimes we acquire these
needs that aren't at anywhere near as
big as as we make them out to be
um you know
um do you have a bed to sleep in do you
have food to eat do you have basic
health care
okay if you start to think okay what are
my needs that I really need and I'm okay
and how can I make Provisions for those
needs
then once you've got that in your mind
you're you're free okay you you can go
beyond that that you may say listen oh I
can do that for a year or two years or a
month or whatever but you I think we
visualize too much the things that we're
used to one of the good things about
this exercise is that you can bring it
brings you back to basics you can be
brought to Basics and like I'm saying if
you have a bed to sleep in and you've
got food
and so on and you have those Basics and
and good relationships with people who
care about you and basic health care so
if you budget for that and you figure
how do you have it maybe it isn't in the
luxurious place you're in maybe it's in
the country and so on once you visualize
that and you get that down in your head
and you say oh I can get that
then your stress will disappear because
you as you visualize that in many ways
that's a happy life it doesn't take a
lot to there's stimulation there's
nature there's relationships these
fundamental
wonderful things the most important
things can be obtained and so for many
of you I think if you look at that and
you budget for that I'm seeing a number
of people
um who are
um going broke
uh and and I've watched this over many
years
and really it's just the adjustment
process when that once they get to that
point where odd you know they have they
get settled
they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's your it's uh icing on the cake
so I want to emphasize you can budget
for that you can look at that find that
scenario
find what that looks like so that you
know you've got it down then you know
you're safe once you've got safe
everything beyond that is luxury rule
number six is always keep learning with
Mark Cuban how do you identify what's
next
you know I I just read a lot right I'm
just one of those guys that just
consumes information the internet or
where everything yeah everything
anywhere I can get I just try to learn
you've always been this way yeah yeah
I've always been like a knowledge geek
where it mostly Tech but it could be
anything I just anything business
related technology related marketing
related you know um culture related I
want to try to stay on top of it you
know Steve Steve Jobs had this this one
quote that really stuck with me he said
everything's a remix and if you look at
the early days of the Apple products
there was this company back in the day
called Xerox Park and Xerox came out
with the first Mouse driven PC
but their marketing sucked and they had
no idea what they were doing no one knew
what they're about Steve Jobs came in a
little bit of this a little bit remixed
and Bam right all of a sudden you got
apple and then a Macintosh and then
they're yeah he made it sexier yeah and
then even he got fired right he got
fired from that company and then they
had to bring him back to make it work
and so you know for me the more you
learn the more you know how to remix and
that's what this is all about so you
know how do you go from YouTube which
was the first platform for video that
got big to Instagram to Snapchat I know
okay do I want to be on Discover do I
want to be on reels do I want to be on
Tick Tock you know and if I do this you
know how's YouTube going to treat me and
all the decisions you guys you guys have
got to make on a daily basis you know
and the fact that like we're just
talking you created all these products
and you want it to be organic that's a
business decision too and then you have
to learn by trial and error right you
were curious about what might work you
know obviously you know you're walking
proof of what does work right and now
you've got to be able to continue to
make those decisions because in this
business with all the margins on these
projects everybody's coming at you all
the time right yeah and they think they
can do the exact same thing but it's not
that easy but for me it's like that's
why I try to stay ahead because whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's VR whether it's crypto whether it's
metaverse all these things may not be
prime time yet but I want to know when
they will be and I want to be out front
when they when they are and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is solve a problem
with Richard Branson there are so many
problems in this world
um and trying to prioritize you know
which problems uh to solve and which you
just feel you don't have the energy for
or the resources for is is a really
tough one
um which is why we're trying to get like
you know every single business in this
room
um even if you're a really small
business I love this kid
um whatever it was eight coming up to me
and pitching me earlier in the in the
corridor
um but um uh but uh and and giving me
one of his products you shouldn't give
away the products anyway
um you're gonna have trouble getting out
of here now that someone knows that you
were pitched in the court they they and
and but um
uh but I think that if if
um every single person in this room uh
can adopt at least one problem and and
you know like you know if it's just uh
you know trying to find a roof over the
the person you keep walking by who's
sleeping in the street every day you
know going to your office if you know
something you know but just a a problem
in this world
um I think
um you know the every single person in
this room will feel you know that much
better for it you know uh in 50 years
time when they've looked back on their
life and their careers and and obviously
as you as businesses get bigger you can
you can you can um adopt bigger and
bigger and bigger problems and you can
use your entrepreneurial skills your
resources your teams to take on on some
of the really big problems of this world
um and I think uh you we cannot let
business let government try to sort
problems the world have they haven't got
the entrepreneurial skills generally to
do so
yeah
uh so and it's great fun I mean you know
we we have um uh we have something
called audacious ideas gathering on
Necker every year where we get some of
the more successful people together and
we uh we get throughout the year with
with Ted we get maybe 300 companies
sorry 300 organizations to pitch
um and then we choose 10 of the of the
most important things in the world to
try to resolve and then we go out to try
to resolve them every year and you know
it could be a particular kind of
blindness in Africa
um uh you know it could be you know how
do we sort out methane leaks around the
world and you know can we use satellites
to spot them and and then alert the
companies these methane leaks
um and so on and as your businesses get
more successful you become more
entrepreneurially aware as to how to
look at situations in this world
um then then you get into a position
where you can actually start tackling
some of the bigger issues things
I am not here satisfy you I am not here
so you like oh oh Grant I like him I
don't care if you like me or not man I
want to move a handful of people in the
room to go from 400 Grand a year to
start thinking about how do I make four
million big boy right over here popping
out what do you would you make last year
would you gross last year
2.7 how does anybody live
you need to make it impossible dude I
cannot I can't my my plane eats 2.7
million dollars a year this dude needs
to think different he's running out of
time man you guys all in the room man
you're running out of time you're in a
space that is so frothy with opportunity
it's unbelievable you're making sense of
less than you can get this is my mama my
mama's saying I love you boy just the
way you are Mama I made 10 million
dollars on one deal that's great but son
I love you just the way you are I'm like
I don't love me just the way I am
because I'm doing deals where I know I
could make a hundred
okay how many of you in a room are
operating below your potential let me
see a hand if you know you're operating
below your potential man please tell me
your Opera how many of you let me see
your hand again if you're operating
below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm going to quit thinking I'm going
to quit thinking that I that I got to do
a four minute mile
I'm going to quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars Within
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied
okay I want to raise the numbers on this
room
so the next time there's 75 people here
and everybody adds a zero to your income
oh by the way if you love yourself at
400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like I do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway good then
get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
get paid some real money just had a zero
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said how
you got add I know
I don't get into customer I want to
multiply customers I wanna I don't want
to add orders I want to multiply my
orders okay I consider myself a decent
salesperson
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros because
you're going to hit you're going to hit
a place where they can't pay you anymore
right or wrong
you got to start thinking about being a
business inside the business
how do I add zeros how do I grow the top
line of my business okay so today I'm
thinking I'm thinking man I'm going to
build a mo I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I just go into
it backwards I'm going to build a 10
billion dollar business I'm going to
take the 14 little things that I have
probably get down to three or four how
do I build 10 billion
I know the money's on the planet say yay
if you agree there's 10 billion dollars
on planet Earth
got to think different and I can't
compare it to my upbringing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
to learn how billionaires think and get
some success advice from the top check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there everybody has a
different talent and the reason we're
all so messed up is because you're
looking at everybody else's talent I
don't fear anything but I worry about
everything